How are ya?
I'm good.
You know how to light up a room.
It's very nice.
Aww!
Thanks for being here.
You're always sweet!
(audience cheers)
[Conan] Thank you. It's very nice.
I haven't seen you in a long time.
Oh! Thanks for being here!
You know, we actually haven't talked
since Friends went off the air.
And it's so strange because
it's been eighteen months.
I don't know how you feel.
That does not feel... it
doesn't feel like Friends
has been off the air for
eighteen months 'cause-
I know.
It's still on all the time.
Well, so it's really not
off the air, actually.
Exactly, yeah, it's still
going and going strong.
Sorry.
Yeah, it's okay.
(audience laughs)
No! People are... I mean, people watch it.
People still love it.
I think they're gonna be
watching that show for a long,
it's gonna be like the Honeymooners.
It'll be on for a long time.
Wow, yeah.
Yeah, they're gonna start showing it
in black and white for no reason.
(laughing)
Do you find yourself passing
TVs every now and then
and the show is on and
do you ever watch it?
I do. Yeah, every once in a while.
If I'm flipping through the channels
and I see it, I do stop watch it.
It makes me happy. (audience laughs)
Oh, that's nice. That's really nice.
It does. I miss it.
You know, what's funny is
that when enough time goes by,
and this is true, you won't remember
what happens in an episode.
No, that's true.
So I'll get to watch it
sort of like you all did?
Yeah, yeah.
And you'll be like, "Oh,
what's gonna happen?"
(Jennifer laughs)
"And who's she? Wait!" (laughs)
That's cause I get old and senile, right?
"That's me."
You know, Lisa Kudrow was here
and she said, when the
show went off the air,
people were talking about
grabbing different stuff
and she grabbed the cookie jar-
She did.
From the set that had
the little clock on it.
And I'm curious, did you grab anything?
I didn't grab anything.
Did I grab anything?
No, I didn't grab anything.
They all stole stuff.
Right, yeah.
(audience laughs)
Yeah. They're all thieves.
Yeah, people say like,
"Oh, I think I took this.
I took that," that's called stealing.
That's stealing. (audience chuckles)
Yeah, that's wrong.
But they felt like 10 years, I own this.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah. Like Matt LeBlanc said
he took a whole sectional
or something from the, you know?
Didn't he take foosball table?
I think he said he was gonna take it
but they stopped him when he
was going through the gate.
They did?
Yeah. (chuckles)
He was just like, "You can't have that."
You know, it's funny. This
is a homecoming for you.
You're from New York city.
Yes!
You were raised here.
I was raised here, 92nd and Columbus.
(audience cheers)
That's nice.
(audience clapping)
Now you can give that address out.
Now I can give that address out.
No. But, yeah.
But you had a good time?
It's such a cool place to
grow up. I would think.
Such a great place.
There's a lot of excitement.
Such a great place. It's so beautiful.
Just, you know, people on the
streets, all walks of life.
I miss that, I do miss that.
'Cause you know, LA you
get in a little bubble.
[Conan] Right.
You travel in the bubble
to your next bubble.
That's your choice to travel
in the a little bubble.
Hey it's my... (laughing)
You should get a car.
Yeah, but it's fun.
It's really fun in there.
(audience laughing)
It's the new bubble, It's
what everyone's doing.
Yeah.
Do you, do you...
I heard a story that you
once slept outside of a hotel
here in New York city.
Yes.
Why did you do that?
The Omni Berkshire Hotel.
[Conan] Mm-hmm.
Because I was, I was having a...
I was a Duran Durani.
I was a Durani fan.
And they were doing Saturday Night Live
and they were the musical guest.
And you know, they say,
"Tonight's guests for, you know,
whatever, are staying at
the Omni Berkshire Hotel."
No, they're not.
And I... (audience laughs)
with my girlfriends went out with a rose
and waited for them to come home,
and they never came home.
And so we stayed out there all night.
I didn't actually sleep
That's so sad.
on the street, that's
a little pathetic, but.
Right, right.
I do that, I sleep on the street.
You do?
When Mr. T is in town-
Even now?
And I know where he's
staying. (audience laughs)
You do?
No, I understand though,
that level of intensity
about I really want to meet this person.
It was really weird of me, I have to say.
It's a little strange phase.
But one thing that's
nice is then you go on
and become a big star, you could meet,
have you ever met
the people from Duran Duran?
Yes I have.
I met Simon Le Bon.
[Conan] Oh, you did?
Yeah, I think I scared him actually.
What happened?
Well, I was with a friend of mine
at a store in Santa Monica.
And my friend saw him and
just basically grabbed him
and said, "Don't move.
You just stay right here.
Don't move."
And ran and got me and was like,
"Jen, you've gotta come here.
You've got to see this.
You've got to see this."
So I think I'm gonna see
something, not someone.
And he basically throws me and I just,
I just, I couldn't believe it.
And I told him, I said,
I slept out in front of a hotel for you.
(Conan laughs)
He didn't say a word.
I mean, he literally didn't speak.
I think we just scared him
and he didn't say anything.
But were you known?
Were you famous Jennifer Aniston then?
Yes.
So I can't believe he
didn't say, "Oh my God.
That's so..." I mean, you know?
No, he just sort of slowly looked at me
like I was nuts and grabbed
my hand and shook it
and then we... it was
a very awkward moment.
I don't really remember it truthfully.
Yeah, yeah. (audience laughs)
I think you blacked out.
I think that's what happened.
I may have.
Yeah.
And you had a traumatic experience
here in New York City
involving Santa Claus.
Santa slapped me.
What? (audience laughs)
This is good.
It was a homeless guy
wearing a Santa's hat.
[Conan] Right.
And I was walking down
Broadway after a dance class
and I was with my girlfriend
and I basically saw this guy standing
in the middle of the street
and I just happened to be
passing him right at the time
that he just went-
[Conan] Oh my God.
And backhanded me-
[Conan] Right, right.
Really hard.
[Conan] Yeah.
And I was stunned, and I was like,
"What the hell are you doing?"
And nobody stopped and...
I don't know what you expect people to do.
Like go beat up the homeless
Santa. (Conan laughs)
Yes, yes.
Something! But there was no, you know.
See, that's New York.
People are just like,
It's very strange.
"Yeah, girl got hit by Santa."
Yeah, whatever.
That happens all the time.
Let's go, you know? (audience laughs)
So.
Yeah, so.
It's fun growing up in New York.
Yeah, these are heart
warming stories, yeah.
Aren't they great? (audience laughs)
I can tell you that the
muggings too, that was fun.
Now let's talk about,
let's talk about Derailed
because I got to see this movie last night
and I really liked it.
And I don't...
It's a very difficult movie to talk about
'cause you can-
Yes.
Give some things away.
So I'm not going to do that.
Great.
It's a suspenseful thriller
with lots of twists.
Yes.
Xzibit is in this movie.
He's one of your co-stars,
and he was on the show the other day.
And he said it was hard for him
because the first day on the set,
literally, the first thing he had to do
as part of his character
was grab you and put a gun to your head
and sort of throw you around.
And he said he was freaked out.
Yeah, he was.
He just really didn't
want to do that to you.
He really didn't.
And he was so sweet.
He just kept apologizing.
And, "Are you okay? Are you okay?"
to the point where I was like,
"You really just got to throw me down."
(audience laughs)
You just don't... I mean, I'm okay.
I'll let you know if it hurts.
Right, Right.
I could see...
(laughing)
Moving on. (audience laughs)
Back to Santa.
Yeah.
It's them, It's not us.
No, it just sounded strange.
They're dirty people.
You're working with, this
is a Swedish director.
Swedish.
Swedish, a Swedish director.
Yeah.
Did you learn any cool Swedish terms?
Swedish words.
Yeah.
He did teach us a couple.
It's hard to remember
the Swedish language.
[Conan] Right.
But-
People remember the cadence.
They remember the hida, hada, hooda, hida.
They remember the cadence, exactly.
Right, right.
And he doesn't really talk
like that at all, actually,
that's not really the way they talk.
Right, right.
I like my stereotypes though.
Do you? So do I. (audience laughs)
Let's just put them in a box.
Irish people are like,
♪ Hoo dee hi dee di dee ho ♪
(audience laughs)
It's just much simpler that way.
Yeah. (chuckles)
No, he's... I don't know if it's canoodle.
Canoodle.
There are certain words
that you just start to...
I don't think-
Canoodle is a Swedish word I guess.
Canoodla.
Yeah.
Isn't it? Canoodla? Canoodle.
But you know, then you
start using it for anything,
like don't you get canoodle-y with me.
What's funny, they also use it
in the tabloids all the time.
They're always talking about celebrities
were seen canoodling in a bar.
Yes.
And I think it's such a,
it's such a weird term.
It's a good word though,
isn't it? It's fun.
It sounds like they're
just making pasta together
or something.
I know. (laughs)
My mom, and this is
true, If two people are,
you know, getting busy, she
calls it playing patty fingers.
[Jennifer] Oh.
She's like, "Oh, I heard he was playing
patty fingers with her."
And I'm like, what are you talking about?
They get together and go heeeeee?
The dumbest thing in the world.
That sounds strange.
She's a strange woman.